apparently when they did this like you
know essentially forensic analysis
of this 30 year old monkey island code
um there was there was so much buried in
there of
sort of relics of iterations of
development in terms of like
old character designs and uh
scenes that had been uh redone and it
the thing that shocked me is is is it a
legacy of that era
that that stuff would have stayed in the
code
because it seems like a big part of the
optimization process and stuff that goes
on in the tail end of games or
throughout development
now is getting rid of that it's getting
rid of all the superfluous crap that's
basically
just in there making a mess so it seemed
insane that this game
had the equivalent of almost like tree
rings where you can like
look back at earlier versions of itself
within itself that that
that baffled me that it was that
complete of a picture of the
of the early stages what what is your
take on that mr biffle
you'd be surprised is my take like i i
think yeah i think a lot it happens a
lot more than people think and you've
you've seen this a few times actually
with modern games
um damn i can't remember i followed this
person on twitter and i cannot remember
their name i'm gonna actually
try baker troy baker i didn't follow
troy baker on twitter my twitter
unfollowed troy
the other day don't try to pawn it off
onto some
genuinely i was like i know i'm
following troy so like i don't know how
many people are accidentally unfollowed
or something
anyway um i'm gonna find who this person
is but there's someone who's been like
digging through like uh dark souls like
not the not the reboot but like
sorry the remaster but like the the
previous version and i think they
also look to demon souls and then the
amount of stuff that's buried in those
games of like
unfound areas or so often in game
development you're just up against it
with time so you don't
you don't delete everything behind that
in that area you just put up a wall
and no one can go in isn't that like
like okay so let's say you ship the game
it's out and then there's always people
kind of you you go down to your
you scale down your your skeleton crew
or whatever and you start
uh patching and you start maybe working
on dlc or whatever it is depending upon
the size of the studio but is there not
someone that's like all right
remember all that [ __ ] that we left
behind or was it just like mount everest
and you just you just leave it up there
you need to just go back and click
really well you well you so you can and
of course you should like of course
you're absolutely right from like an
optimization point of view you don't
want any assets in the game
that you don't need but yeah of course
like you you can leave it there so
therefore it stays there yeah
and and it also coincides a lot quite
often with like how
wasteful you can be from a performance
um
and file size point so and i might be
wrong
is monkey island was that like a was
that one of the first kind of cd-rom
adventure games or was it before that i
think it pre-dates
i was going to say if it was cd-rom
sometimes that would be an excuse of
like well you've got all this space on
the cd-rom you don't really care
necessarily you can leave it in there
but yeah i think most games have bits
and pieces
so like um my game is definitely like
there's definitely bits of my games
if you did something like this you would
find stuff i'm not going to say anything
more than that because i want to
encourage anyone to actually go looking
i know
i mean i would just think from a purely
purely from a
um like
your exposure in that is just crazy like
people could go back and
and find all sorts of nefarious
things to to at least hack a game if
nothing else i was talking to my buddy
the other day we were we were talking
about how
um like games like mist speaking of sp
cd-rom games right
so that that like shipped with so many
uh
computers and i i got uh zoric grand
inquisitor because it shipped with
like my gateway computer or whatever um
there were no
he travis said on miss that he never got
uh
past a certain level because there was a
glitch
in the program and in the code that
he couldn't click on something because
there was a camera break or something
and so he could never actually interact
with the item that he had to do
so he was done yeah and it was like
there were no
patches oh god they're not right so you
couldn't just go hey
are bad like assassin's creed i remember
this was
probably three or something said that
they shipped with a thousand
known bugs because you just gotta get
out the door and everyone's like
it just became a joke it's like day one
patch right we're gonna fix it all but
not being able to do that it's like
that's a bygone era
of and and like monkey island is a
perfect proof of that of like here's 30
year old code
or the same thing jordan magner did the
same thing with prince of persia right
he was like here's
he he lost that code and his dad just
happened to find it
in a box in the attic of his rich i was
like
that is a seminal game it became a well
we could talk about standards if we
wanted to as far as like
is it is it still is monkey island
30 years on right three decades of game
iteration and and all sorts of crazy
stuff that happened
there's a whole generation of people
right now that
are making games because that are
influenced by the games that they're
making now are influenced by the games
that they played right
right mike you are making games in some
way
based upon the games that you played
that left an indelible mark on you
you're like
i wanted to have this kind of feeling
i'm taking credit for all the ideas i'm
stealing from all those old games
borrowing and emulating deus ex allows
you to change
deus ex had allowed you to change the
color of the ui i duplicated that
functionality and solitaire conspiracy
and i still see
20 year olds going on about how it's so
cool you can change the color of the ui
nobody tell them nobody tell them that
was standard on pc games
until but that's more important more
inspector sitting there going hey wait a
minute
i saw it curry wants more inspector he
likes curry fair play he was good
we're going to get to the point to where
we're further and further away from what
we consider the standard
right like this is a great game
so does that mean just like that code
you leave it there and it's it serves as
as a
a benchmark of what was the standard of
excellence
or is it no now the standard of
excellence is this and this gets
disregarded
i think like citizens i don't think you
get rid of it i think you're
contextualized we're seeing this and i'm
not saying that thomas was alone as a
classic by any means
but we're seeing this with thomas was
alone with like its score on
different websites we're seeing so after
tomorrow i think i mentioned this on the
last show like thomas was alone the
review scores went up
and now what we're seeing in like steam
reviews and stuff is the review score's
going down a little bit
not much but by a little bit because
thomas was alone if you come to thomas
was alone on steam let's say you're
someone who i know you're watching this
show and you're like i'm gonna check out
what that
that idiot englishman makes and you you
grab thomas learn and play it
it is not as good as celeste do you know
what i mean like there's
the indie indie platformers have moved
on kind of in the time
since then you know it's what an apple
an orange is
comparison though yeah yeah completely
but like
but you know what i mean like in terms
of role in terms of feeling of game i
would say thomas was alone definitely
feels like
a previous generation it's not it's been
surpassed by games that have come since
as it should be that's a sign of a good
healthy industry um
but i guess my point is like you
recontextualize you look at thomas was
alone we you know we're
we're re-releasing thomas was alone on
switch it is
a thing that we are now seeing players
are nostalgic for
from you know i played your game as a
kid i mean you've definitely heard that
about journey right austin
yeah but that's like that's eight years
ago right seven years ago
yeah it's just enough time it's just
enough time that people
no longer think of themselves as a kid
and i love that someone
could be like 12 years old and now
they're 20. and so there's someone who's
working for
me right now who showed me some fan art
they made the thomas was loan when they
were kids
i mean that's how far it's been that's
how long it's been it's crazy
and the in the in the time the time
horizon of that can be even shorter neil
uh neil druckmann mentioned to me that
there's someone who was working
his work yeah yeah it's usually
very safe and and controversy free
um yeah he um no one's ever done
anything
to yeah yeah it's a miracle you've heard
of him to be frank but uh he's
very quiet very retired yeah
he said that
[Laughter]
i think that's accurate he said that um
there was
uh one or two team members at on the
last of us part two at naughty dog that
basically said that about the last of us
they were like effectively
i grew up playing the last of us and now
now they're like just old enough to
basically have joined the industry and
and they're working you know their dream
job at naughty dog like look if they're
25 that's
true yeah yeah exactly
that's basically the subtext here is
we're all old that's the
but also we get old quite fast
apparently
like really yeah a couple of years ago
you know
young upstarts uh you know
turning heads and doing new things and
then like three years later the old
guard
uh some of the soul heads some of us
still tell you that
it's like the um it's like in starship
troopers where they're like you know
we're the old men now at rico's
roughnecks and
like literally six months earlier they
were new recruits
um industry doesn't have a time of like
war and fighting
bugs i was gonna say yeah that the
industry doesn't uh
the industry doesn't uh mangle its
members quite as aggressively
like citizen kane since it came out in
what 1939
is that right or am i conflating that
with um wizard of oz
wizard that was 1929 39 was definitely
the year that had like five classic
films come out it's one of those
legendary
years 35-39 1998 of movies
41 41 was citizen kane
where are you that doesn't seem right
well [ __ ] you willing to trust wikipedia
yeah
um the reason why i say that is because
like that
to me i don't even know a lot of people
that have seen like look we do a film
screening every
every saturday and it's it's surprising
what people haven't seen
um it's just like how have you gone
through life in this country and not
have
seen batman like tim burton's batman
um especially their response is like
well i'm 18
and i'm not american right but i'm also
talking about people that like
oh i'm not outing her but like ashley
johnson had never seen tim burton's
batman
and i was like holy crap and it's
there's nothing that's greater than like
experiencing something that we have held
dear
and like have wrapped up in ourselves in
nostalgia oh yeah
and sharing it with someone for the
first time i did that with um
aliens i i had never seen aliens and i
finally write we were literally about to
watch it and it was
uh travis willingham yuri lowenthal and
liam o'brien
at my apartment i was like i've never
seen this movie before and
the the bellow of joy that just erupted
from them they were like i can't believe
we get to watch this with you for the
first time
and vicarious yeah the vikings i love
that i can't get enough that i love
introducing people to movies for that
reason
it's like re-watching it for the first
time right getting to feel that energy
coming off someone it's oh i'm a vampire
for i love but it is interesting
although have you ever had it
uh well have you ever though before you
shift have you have you ever had it
where you're vicariously feeding on that
and they're it's not working and it's
like it's heartbreaking
it's definitely you gotta it's like
relationships you gotta put yourself out
there you gotta allow yourself to be
hurt to truly feel joy
um it's true there's nothing i had a
friend of mine that would do that and
like
every they would do like weekly they
would say okay tonight we're gonna watch
this thing and this was like i need you
to understand this is what i grew up
this was my
like it would be like cool hand luke or
something it was like you don't
understand what this movie means to me
and this is someone who's younger than
him and so they would sit and she would
just be like
i don't get it and he would have to go
okay cool but she could find something
else
that maybe came out 10 years later that
she could be the same way about
and that's all that we're seeing right
now is all these reboots and and
revisitings and remasters and everything
else
we've talked about this so much but it's
just curious to me if that standard of
excellence now moves and it's like
to me godfather will always be a great
movie because there's nothing
about it that is of a time you know
there's nothing i can think of
performances even though it's a period
piece
there's nothing about it the camera
language everything is still but maybe
i'm i'm
jaded by my own perspective i don't know
i think it is probably
it it has it has hallmarks of its era
more than you're letting on like that
doesn't make it dated
well even just like an obvious one is
just the literal fact of shooting it on
film
uh like there are and the way things are
lit accordingly as a result
and and you know obviously the fact that
it's a hundred percent practical effects
like things that we take for granted uh
you know
you start to say ah okay that doesn't
look like
a movie that was made in 2020 or 20 or
2000 or 19.
the grammar of it and the kind how long
they hold a shot the editing choices
like i imagine
i bet if you showed the godfather to
like
a 15 year old now they would think that
was like an old person's movie
they would i feel like inevitably would
move on
to troy's point though i do think that
it does
it has aged so well and maybe by the
time that 15 year old is 20
or 25.
it's the best media 72 that could watch
that movie and be like oh this is moving
that's fantastic um go back to the sunny
at the toll booth and that's about
all that you're gonna get but you're
absolutely right like that that is that
is a
that is of of that time like that's a
70s shot
where the squibs were kind of like
it's a very practical shot and there's
nothing about it that but i don't know i
mean there's still a lot like in star
wars we did it
um where i would prefer the practical
then i would prefer the cg mandalorian
notwithstanding
so lauren's at a point now where they've
cycled back and they're now doing
special
they're doing cg effects that look
practical right there's a lot of stuff
in the mandalorian
that is intentionally like some of the
animation's a bit shaky
they're intentionally trying to make
stuff look a little rickety a little bit
um handmade to to emulate that vibe but
that's
yeah i guess that's the song but i
assume i mean i assume
you're not blowing my mind right now
right like the the baby yoda
the now named character of baby yoda uh
the child
um that's he's always practical right
always um so he is
i'm going very well like no he is but
this i there i'm
i'm not certain but i think there's like
a layer of cg on top it's similar to um
in force awakens there's the simon pegg
the the
the character who run who owns the
planet the um
i don't remember anything about that
movie that the the protagonist
right lady luke skywalker ray the raise
i'm so sorry i'm not making a big point
here i just don't remember this film at
all
um right the the the planet rays on
where she's got like there's the slaves
so yeah that's that's a practical
animatronic head
that they've then done like a cg touch
up on so they can get them yeah
so i assume they're doing the same thing
with baby odor that it's yeah 90
puppet but probably there's some tweaks
to a facial expression here and there or
a little
and his movement like oh it's
intentionally a bit yeah it feels like a
puppet it looks like a jim henson
yeah yeah which i think is very charming
which is more polarizing
episode 1 episode 4 or episode 7.
uh honestly i don't even know
episode 4 is universally beloved so i
don't think that that's polarizing like
even in it's
in its day before you watch i've shown
four to people who've never seen it
before and it's
genuinely like people still go oh i get
why this is still around
like this is a genuinely great film even
to a new audience
and i would argue one's better than you
remember as well
when was the last time you watched
phantom menace that's my controversial
take of the show
i'm he's totally fine i'm totally fine
with phantom menace except when that
brat shows up all the jojo are you an
angel
um oh that one oh yeah young anakin
i i here's the here's the thing it's
just disappointing because it just feels
like a remake of four that's the biggest
yeah that's the thing angel i would say
it's amazing
and like i would have taken annie and
and like what darth vader did to the
emperor and i would just throw him into
the
that's what you know the funny thing
about that is
i would do that to that kid a lot of
people said in the bud right now
there were so many people that were like
we don't need to see
young child darth vader that was their
take they were they were very disturbed
but i haven't
seen patton oswalt he was like i don't
need to know because
do you like ice cream here's some rock
salt
i i don't i don't i don't necessarily
disagree with that
but the original teaser poster
of jake lloyd casting the shadow of
darth vader under the hut
of of uh the tatooine little house i was
like that
i want to see that movie yeah like and
it so i think i think i think seven is
the most divisive or polarizing
uh i think it's just felt like a step
back it just felt like
because but but i'm i'm not allowed to
be in star wars conversations because i
loved the second
i loved eight the the what's the which
one's that the last jedi
i thought that was incredible i watched
that movie i was like oh star wars is
interesting again they could go in a
million directions
that's really cool um fans hated it
right
so i feel like not since the oj verdict
were there more people walking out of
the same thing going
totally different
[Laughter]
i i walked out of the theater i was like
that was oh
absolutely that was awesome people like
how could you how dare you sir
how dare you i was like what i knew when
when episode seven dropped
i was like okay i understand what we're
in for i i i see
how we're going to do this whole thing
it's not going to be like this huge
shift you can't steer that ship that far
when you know you're doing seven
eight nine so once seven came i was like
okay i got it i know what we're gonna do
and so i was allowed to just kind of
throw off
making it a good film we need it to be a
good film no we don't
it's star wars we need it to be
something that is spectacle and it's a
space opera that's what i wanted it to
be
and it did eight did everything i wanted
to be
nine was just like a swiss cheese of a
script
it had so many plot holes and it's just
like that's what you needed to do
okay but it feels like it's like a
retcon right it feels like it's trying
to solve a bunch of problems it
perceives with eight like it kill it's
it's trying to like right the ship but
i didn't think the ship was off you know
it was very obvious that they didn't
have a meeting
i i said this countless times it was
like watching nine was like being in an
airplane with really bad turbulence it
was
it was bumpy shaky and scary and
ultimately we were just glad that we had
landed the plane
i was just like we're done i totally
agree i i saw the other day
the other day was the fifth anniversary
of rogue one and somebody was tweeting
that's not an anniversary you can't do
that you can't say uh oh it's the fifth
anniversary that's like
a couple that celebrates their
three-month anniversary of dating
don't do that by the way if you're if
you do that you don't there's no cause
to celebrate
as we celebrate our one year anniversary
of this one hot take yeah if there's one
hot take it's like but you can't
three months what have you been doing
for three months that's just because
you've never had a relationship that
lasted longer than three months
normally we either break up or we go to
dinner and make this
someone some some like some like 20 year
old is watching this
with their three celebration ring and a
tear is running down their eye right now
that's right
from the life of the love of that
audience surely from a
financial prudence standpoint you should
not celebrate a three-month anniversary
and walk into that relationship and
settle that go look i think it's setting
a preston that you're not going to be
able to maintain
every three months we're going to do
this because when you when you get to 9
months
or 15 months then what do you do uh you
don't want to get that you don't go to
that road
you don't want to go to jared's and
they'd be like hi gary
like ass what month is it this time gary
it's like i don't know man
gary when we started talking about rogue
one that's good it's gary witter you
were talking about right now that's what
you're doing it's exactly lovely
gary's the one that used to celebrate
with anniversaries and and
yeah wrote yeah they they cut him out of
the deal so he sells
he sells jewelry now um yeah
it's uh this is what happens when
alana's not here
this is good no we've we've gone we've
followed the job we're getting cut
all of this is getting none of this
isn't yeah is she alive is she i feel
like
hi hey what dude who are you
we're all what's up hello we're
wandering around
monkey island we've done star wars a lot
and then we've done now oh what are you
serious
yeah so thank you so much hey everybody
[Laughter]
in order for me to i had to make this
decision i was like okay
this meeting's gonna take a long time i
can't get out of it but i did have to
spend the five minutes to make the
coffee because i felt bad about joining
the show without having made one
well i was like okay i'll just add an
extra five on top of this
here here is where i think we will know
that this podcast has had
influence and even better a positive
influence
and that is if we can get mike bethel to
stop drinking pepsi
what's the issue with pepsi you know
what it is it's i remember we have to do
this like five minutes before every
episode i don't have time to make a
coffee for myself that's that's the
god's honest truth that's the story i
feel like
uh i can tell the day you've had whether
or not you sit down with your perfect
little curated
you know artistic cup of coffee yes or a
pepsi
and then a pepsi i was like oh he's had
them it's been a pepsi day yeah no it's
been a pepsi day
definitely oh yeah because it's a
different time for you i don't know if
this is normal but
i would never want to drink a soft drink
as it were
before like 3 p.m i knew a lot of people
that did that that was their morning cup
of coffee was like a big dr pepper it
was their
coffee obviously immoral
yeah that's wrong yeah we're past coffee
clock here
we're past coffee o'clock here so yeah
exactly it'd be weird because what is it
like 8 30 for you right now
it's nine right now for me nine ten
possible weird for you to drink a coffee
right now i think
it'd be weird would not be the first
time i've drank a coffee at nine o'clock
though it's because yeah i actually
i'm gonna learn yeah i'm the opposite i
i love
you you know you go to you go to a
restaurant uh finish your meal at like
ten
they bring you an espresso or a couple
that's
or something when you know you're going
on something yeah it's great um yeah
yeah but that that's like
uh either we've had like a really i
would only do that like if i was
in europe would i do that so can we get
you some espresso well yeah but if they
didn't offer it i would be like by the
way before i leave i'd like to have a
coffee
i will do it at virtually any italian
restaurant
you'll do what but any italian
restaurant espresso i'll get the
cappuccino
with dessert garden
of course everyone's favorite i haven't
been but
dominoes
uh you know little caesars
that's a dxa yeah traditionally i'm
still upset that i've not been told what
the star wars talk specifically was
though did you guys talk about
mandalorian
which is no longer which is more
polarizing episode one four or seven
we did also talk about baby yoda as a
practical we did we did so don't don't
brush past some mandalorian
glow i think seven
is more polaroid yeah
we're we're glad we uh we agreed right
now it's great it's an echo chamber it's
excellent
reinforcement consensus is everyone kind
of agrees that one is
bad i don't i don't
i don't okay so i i'm with you yeah i
actually enjoy one uh
however when people are like i i
strongly dislike this film it isn't
something that i find to be polarizing
i'm like that's fair
but it's a movie that i like more than
most people
yeah i think i think it's fine i think
all three
all three of the prequels are
they they benefit from hindsight no
that's the thing forgettable is actually
an interesting choice of word to me
seven eight and nine are forgettable
there are so many moments in the
two things that happen in one two three
don't remember nine
that's already better than the but you
were an adult when they came out troy
that's the that's the difference
right that's the thing the audience now
like those are their star wars films
there's a like you talk to like anyone
in their 20s that's what they grew up
with
no i don't know i'm sure the comments
like and subscribe and share your
comments and subscribe
let's do it um here's a question for you
would you say
that harry potter is is a christmas
movie it's a holiday movie
i live in england all the time so it's
not particularly special to me
true uh no um
i i i just tweeted today that i think
the fellowship of the ring is a
christmas movie
um i wanted to ask you about that i saw
that
to elaborate my my actual thesis
is that all that term ever means and
ever has to mean is that it's something
that you watch around christmas
like that's something that i want to
watch at christmas because it's a group
of people getting together
it's quite celebratory there's a party
it's festive
uh it doesn't matter to me that it's not
i mean there are elves
it doesn't matter to me that it's not
snowing and that nobody's talking about
christmas
um i think that it doesn't have to be
that restrictive but it suits the vibe
is kind of my point so harry potter
specifically about and it's interesting
you bring up lord of the rings we were
talking specifically about harry potter
and there was this
uh in our big chat whatever um
and there was this start spot
polarizing half the people were like
harry potter's absolutely holiday movie
and then other people were like it
absolutely isn't and the reason why the
the market delineation was people that
saw it in the theater
and people that did not hmm
harry potter franchises as well as lord
of the rings
both came out at christmas time
so that's why we considered it a
christmas movie
it's because that's just that's just
guilty by association then basically
by definition they're movies that take
place during the school year right so
they're
they're never there at christmas yeah
but they go spring summer
fall like it always starts on harry's
birthday but like lord of the rings is
agnostic of any season
but it's because lord of the rings came
out december 19th
so it's like i i naturally associate
that's what goes back to the very
beginning
i like avatar avatar's christmas movie
what's that
avatar avatar christmas i think avatar
came out on christmas day if i
i'll never i'll never forget yeah this
was an interesting i'll never forget
no one has ever said the phrase i'll
never forget about avatar before
ever no not history
this is this is meta i was not crazy
about the film it i
i bogs my mind that they're making like
40 more of them
i have a theory but i'll let you you've
continued well so here was the thing i
remember
avatar came out on i think on christmas
day or christmas eve which means that of
that
year and i'm blanking what year was 07
or something like that
sure um whatever year that was it was
only
in theaters for that year for like what
five days six days um did you say he was
seven when avatar came out no two
thousand
it came out oh seven i was like that
doesn't make any sense austin
awesome i think i think i like the part
um no so it this was the thing
the forbes or you know time whoever did
their
top 10 highest paid hollywood
people of the year um
and james cameron was like number
six or seven or something on the list or
or maybe even higher
with like a hundred million dollars or
something from
from profit participation on avatar
and that was from it being in theaters
for like five days
for for that year it came out on
christmas day and it put him in the top
10
most earning people of the year from the
one week
and think about how much money it made
after that like it's
it's insane to me because in in
hindsight it's like why is this
movie so outrageously successful
okay yeah i have i have the answer go um
and so i saw that movie in theaters four
times
i don't like that movie so you you
personally you made it
i can tell you why i did it so i would
say 200 million per ticket
the the way to get me to do anything
like my most go-to social activity
anyone ever asked me to see a movie i
say yes
ever even it's a movie i've seen twice
any of my friends ask would be like yes
uh i love going to the theater i i like
experience would have been a really good
reaction to something that we can
talk about like it's something i will
always do but with avatar specifically
the reason that people kept wanting to
go see it
is just because of the 3d it just looked
different to anything we'd seen at the
time so people
wanted to see it as like a phenomenon
that they'd never seen
a sort of realistic 3d movie that was it
that's why that movie was successful
everyone was told they had to see it and
now they're making a franchise out of it
but that's never going to work again
that's the thing that confuses me purely
logistics there's no way that those
movies are ever going to recoup because
there's the
the the theater the cinema is dead
yeah it's hurting real bad i mean i hate
to say that
i'm not being a doom and gloom guy i
mean i'm the perennial optimist
mike has just left
i knew you were looking for an avatar
i don't know i think it's going to be i
think it was already in decline that's
the thing
this kicked it while it was down i
bought a projector this week and i'm not
going back to the theater i'm done like
having at home now and being able to
like watch a movie on the big screen
like
i'm done is the experience i really do i
i i i like the communal thing experience
the communal exactly
and especially where in la and there's
there's there's other places that have
this but it was like
we would literally be able to make a
night of it because the arclight had
like a great restaurant you go and
there's a specific
sandwich that you get there it's really
good you get a drink you there's a lot
of them that was like hey this is a 21
and up only screen so
and i love the i love the i love the
like culture
that's one of the things i love about la
is the movie-going culture where
there's very few [ __ ] in the
theaters because everybody is like
half the people are in the industry they
stay for the credits they like
and and the arclight will always put you
know behind the scenes stuff
after the credits that people stay for
and then what i also love though is when
you go to the little arc light
restaurant and they go what time is your
movie and they write it down so that
they can like make sure you're getting
your food on time and out the door
so you don't miss the movie i'm like man
this is this is what happens when
people really love film and the ritual
of going to see it i love that alamo as
well
in la and i love the alamo in san
francisco that is probably why i see him
well and i remember the like i i went to
the alamo draft house like the
the og in austin and those guys
were they created a culture where as the
movie house they saw was already in
decline
and what they could do to it and there
were other people that were saying what
if we made a dinner and a movie the same
thing and so we
we charged a premium and we put people
in tables
and the best was this one called the
granada and the granada was i saw an
interview with the vampire there
and this tells you how long ago it was
that was still in theaters first of all
and you you would get like really bad
food there's like buck out of wings and
a bucket of beer
and if you wanted to smoke you could
just do do so on the balcony and so
i saw an interview with the vampire this
old
majestic theater that used that still
had the orchestra pit
um so when they would actually play the
score for the movie
um smoking cigarettes and drinking beer
it was like
that that to me is what is you don't get
that anymore
i am actually really i think that that
that movies
can come back and i think that drive-ins
will become
uh a big thing again um i think they're
already oh
i think people are definitely this last
year they're like a pop-up novelty
though but i think i think that it's
going to wear i think it's a stop gap i
think it's going to the appeal of it's
going to wear thin
uh and for me it's certainly very
unappealing like i don't want to sit
i don't want to sit with my hand on the
[ __ ] you know shifter
and like behind the steering wheel or
what like
it's that is a very unappealing way for
me to watch a movie
i think i think people took silent disco
and drive in and made it a thing to
where it's like it's it's about
tailgating so you go to the thing and
the thing about drive-ins was never i
don't know if anybody's really old
enough to to remember drive-ins but i do
and you would go and it became this
communal thing you could watch the movie
if you wanted to
but because you could only hear the
sound if you were in your car
you could get out of your car and just
like go hang out with people and people
would just hang on the parking lot it
was this very it was this
this mixture of a outdoor event
go in your car you go and you make out
it was like that
that's that's what drive-ins were the
only reason that would appeal to me is
if it's a movie i've seen
a thousand times because yeah we put
that down
in that scenario me and austin are like
the 14 year olds
in the car paying absolute attention
while everyone else is having fun
we're trying to guys can you
we had um hailstorms in the city that
i'm from in australia like
semi-frequently um and anyone who's
parked on a street
thus has a mad dash to find a parking
garage to put their car in
uh and i remember maybe twice that
became a social experience
of everyone waiting for the hail to pass
so their cars weren't getting damaged
people would bring snacks and drinks and
like sit
in the boots of their car just hanging
out talking to other people someone's
playing music it like becomes this
bizarre
party that's cool people are waiting for
the hail to pass it feels like this
post-apocalyptic though of like there's
like monsters roaming around and you
see like the sweeping searchlights
outside and you're like
i mean you definitely can't see anything
that's when you understand like why
humans have done okay is that in those
moments like what happened to us a
couple of weeks ago i think i could send
you guys photos like
we were there was a fire alarm went off
in my building like at midnight
so everyone went spills down to the
street and it was the only contact most
of us had had with like
strangers like for a while of like a
long time just getting to know your
neighbors it's the most i've spoken to
anyone in this who lives in this
building
you were like the old night in the last
crusade i knew you would come
it was genuinely like it was a weirdly
like
because we're all out there in our like
[ __ ] pajamas and [ __ ] but
was just like a nice human yeah like it
was a nice human moment it was nice to
like
have this interaction it was and that's
why you know i pulled that fire accord
every friday
night i was gonna say i knew it was you
i was gonna say this was a social
experiment
i knew it yeah i mean humans not so bad
sometimes but the
my neighbor and his girlfriend have been
arguing
every day or every second day for the
last month and a half
do you get in on it yeah you're weighing
in or trying to mediate
at some point i feel like the answer is
probably not but i keep being like at
some point do i say something
yeah these people need to break up it's
gonna be more worrying if suddenly that
stops
if suddenly there's no fighting you're
going to get worried it's going to be
yeah i'd probably be a bit worried but
they'll be like i don't want to be with
you anymore i don't want to [ __ ] be
with you anymore you're a piece of [ __ ]
but then why are you back the next day
and it's it's so uh so aggressive
pull the fire alarm pull the fire line
everybody out the parking lot
pull the fire alarm yeah mike bethel i
think that if anybody does something
to the point to where like a perfect
example two people are having a fight in
an argument
and they're like yelling at it and
someone walks by it's like hey man like
hey mind your own business like
you've made it my business because now
everything that's happening you've put
on display
for for for a public viewing so i think
if your neighbors like if you're
the same way of like if they're going to
do anything that makes noise
i i always hate it when someone says
don't be rude i'm like they're the ones
that are being rude
if if they're impeding on like keep it
to yourself but if i was cranking thrash
metal at three o'clock in the morning
people go well don't
don't don't don't be rude no tell the
guy to shut the [ __ ] up
i won't do it and i know that i should
let's like
so the same same neighbor used to play
music really loudly at 9am and we would
shoot
inside gaming daily at 9 30 and i would
have to figure out a way to filter
out the fact that he was playing really
loud music every morning until
eventually i had to be like
dude you're making my job difficult you
gotta you gotta stop but i felt bad to
ask that question i felt bad to be like
please
stop playing loud music the arguments
are different though because i just want
everyone to be okay but then i think if
i say something then they'll just yell
at me
yeah so i'm like of course oh that's
always the way in that scenario you're
then the bad guy you'll unify them
it's like exactly what i was going to
survive
we make peace
yeah can you do you want to come visit
troy and you can be like hey you guys
need to stop arguing every day
dude i love it can i pay you to be my
bad guy
it's i don't really think it's a bad guy
because thank you so much for coming
in and uh brought you know bringing us a
perspective and a relationship it was
like
hey hey um philip what's what's your
problem with daphne
you know and dad you feel like a
mediator i just don't think that he sees
me as a hey guys
look at her man phillip i mean i can
tell you what all their problems are i'm
aware of their issues
um it's quite loud i'm also not
actively bothered by it outside of being
like
who's the who's you who do you think
but she is very bad at communicating
[Laughter]
watching this right now they're like is
that the girl across the whole yeah
philip and daphne are watching this [ __ ]
right now listening now yeah
i hope so man it's intense um what would
be amazing is if
tomorrow screams irrationally even
though what he's doing is wrong and he's
very measured so
that they just can't communicate about
it oh so it's always working that winds
her up more because he's very
pretty much always one-sided yeah my
fantasy is that saturday morning you're
gonna
you're gonna hear the new no it's gonna
be it's gonna be
you heard what she said you're the one
who's irrational i'm the one
i always liked episode three more than i
liked episode two
yeah see we're healing we're healing
people one one
time they were gonna celebrate their
three-month anniversary troy
i guarantee you philip and daphne
celebrated a three-month anniversary
once it came in it just was the law of
diminishing returns it got worse and
worse and worse
i had an upstairs neighbor and he was a
brilliant pianist and and i would love
to listen to him play piano
but if late at night and apparently his
bedroom was right above
my bedroom if late at night i all of a
sudden heard
sade i knew that i was in for a long
night
because that was that man's [ __ ] music
and he would put on
sade and and he was he was a very large
man
and any woman that he brought back to
his apartment it was like
it just wasn't it was never there was no
sweet love making going on it was just
a violent exchange of emotions always
the same
it was always the same thing it was
always it was always shoddy
that's like yes i was like oh here we go
like that that's like
an indecent proposal was like that's how
i want to make a love tool it's
it's it's sleeping with the enemy where
where he always uh he always plays the
the berlioz uh of course he's fantastic
straightens the towels yeah exactly yeah
he always
it's the dia sire you know that
it's literally it's literally the day of
wrath uh is what that
much like an aphrodisiac to me no that's
the funniest
yeah what's it patrick bergen right yeah
the man with the mustache
he looks he looks exactly like my father
uh that that movie it's hilarious
he doesn't i don't see that his best
performance by the way
is in uh this this independent movie
with val kilmer and he plays like this
kind of cleaner assassin guy
and he's on the phone in the middle of
the museum
and he's smoking his cigarette he's on
the phone and some guy walks up to him
and he's like sir you you uh please be
quiet and you can't smoke in here and he
just looks at it with those crazy eyes
he goes
[ __ ] off turns right and walks away
oh it's so good oh man patrick bergen
shout out
love it yeah there's no stone unturned
with this podcast
we've definitely good luck labeling this
one too well what i was going to ask you
guys about today
was going to be scalpers
yeah there you go yes for consoles my
question was going to be along the lines
of have you a seen
how much drama there is about this and b
what do you think the solution is um so
some some of the stuff that's going down
is basically there are a ton of
people who naturally always bought a
bunch of consoles
um
bots uh to resell them at a higher price
and there's been some very funny things
that have come out of it i have a friend
lance mcdonald
who is intentionally putting 10 000 to
twenty five thousand dollar bids on each
of them on ebay
uh so that the scalpers get trolled and
his account will always get banned
when he never pays them the money but
he's basically delaying purchases
so nobody buys the scalpers gets screwed
over which i think is brilliant
that's fine um very funny i should say
by the way
weird coincidence sorry just to
interrupt you lance when i said earlier
that there was someone who mods
demon souls and i couldn't remember the
name lance mcdonald
we did it guys that's a weird kind of
a lot of without even having heard you
say that just swooped in with the enemy
i kind of want everything that's
incredible that is hosting yeah he's
he's a game dev and his daughter um i've
tweeted about her uh twice now uh
i'm doing the show like this from now on
what's happening here what's going on
here
we're all doing austin's positions are
we doing the chill oh
um i'm too tall my chair is too
ergonomically satisfying
and published it on steam and it has all
these like really positive reviews
she like finished portal when she was
really young anyway um
yes lance is doing that ant-man fight
dragon on twitter lance is great
uh but otherwise there was this facebook
thread from the scalpers
we're doing story hour and alana's
telling us the story yeah
you're all six years old about the
scalpers so the
is children on facebook
made a post saying no okay made a post
saying that
uh they have to families to feed to they
have to take advantage of this economy
and it's not fair that people are seeing
them so negatively
uh when the companies who have sold
these which is like your best buyers
yeah amazon's whatever
have made it so easy for them to take
advantage of the system
i i the thing that is hard to the
the thing that is very difficult for me
to accept about
that argument is they have to basically
front hundreds of dollars in order to
buy the console initially in the hopes
of what a
ten percent profit like they're not
going to sell it for what a thousand
bucks what are they selling it for
like so yeah 500 i mean is it a big i
think one did sell for ten thousand
dollars
really oh come on wait a week jesus
christ really i know
i'm sorry well first of all we should
say by the way alana does work at sony
yes we are talking about places i think
i covered that
that's true we put it in there for you
we put it in there i'll get in on this
um
because the microphone is going to be
again
because i've got blurry because of how
good your take's about to be that's what
it is
it's going to be super hot get ready um
there was um i think in in the turn of
the century turn of the 20th century
90 of the cars on the road were electric
it's fascinating 90 of the cars on the
road were electric we have moved
backwards now we're coming back to where
we believe
most cars obviously because of carbon
emissions should all be electric if it's
a far
better more um and you could talk to
environmentalists and and just even
changing the hybrids is going to not do
what we needed to change the
the uh at the turn of say that again
this is the third century they would
i think you've said it were electric
we're electric
like on the road or being sold that
we're on the road we're electric that
can't possibly be true
they're up against new york city in in
like because the way that the
uh they would have to get rid of every
old car
there are cars on the road that have
been on the road since the 70s like
no no no i'm saying 1900.
oh the return of the turn of the turn of
the 20th century
trying to turn this way i think he did
say that but i'm still confused
that now now i'm so they have to say
my point is this my point is this no no
i'm really well digging is this horse no
i think you mean horse drawn right you
mean non
you mean non petrol you mean no it's
i'll i will i will find the quote i was
fascinated by this it was because you're
talking you're also talking like at that
time there's like 10 cars
right so the percentage is not
necessarily what's mattered but
we found that there was an easier way to
make cars to use a combustible engine
but the the fact is that we created that
infrastructure that is predicated upon
something that is inherently bad
but in order to undo that we would have
to
you can't just go okay no more
combustible engines and everything has
to be hybrid because you would force
you would for the record i don't think
anybody wants a combustible engine
mike mike's with me not a combustible
engine but
you can't just say all cars must now be
hybrid or plug-in electric because that
would
that would flood the market globally
with uh
unemployment so the the you're right it
is possible for someone
there's more to it than that there's a
long there there is a
uh there is a market that exists right
now to where i can as a person
go and purchase something and then sell
it if i want it is not illegal to sell
something
at a markup it is it is unethical
maybe but it is not illegal but in order
to
change that what is what is um what is
becomes a prerequisite in order to
change that system
is so fundamentally convoluted and
and entangled in all it
you're basically saying we need to get
rid of capitalism and there's a lot of
people that would agree that we need to
but that's the plot twist of the second
year of this show let's
bring down character we've worked with
let me tell you about a little thing i
call socialism
um it's basically it's just capitalism
scalping is
literally capitalism it's taking
capitalism and selling something
for a problem yeah especially the thing
you did not make
in the individual right it is that's
true of most capitals
right like good night
yeah i uh i i think there's some straw
manning going on here
but but uh it's not
scalpers don't represent the
the like end destination and idealized
form of capitalism
capitalism the the ideal form
is that the revenue that sony let's say
in the case of the ps5
is making that's what drives the
production of more so scalpers
is are essentially a short-term
secondary effect that yeah there will
always be those kinds of things but it's
it's not itself like
some kind of goal as if you're you're
enshrining it as though
it is from that objective of the scalper
it might not match the playstation's
capitalistic objective but it matches
the scalper's capitalistic objective
but not well yeah well at the end of the
day the capitalist objective
is to provide something of valuable to a
consumer that they would be
therefore motivated to part with their
dollars in exchange for
and if sony is making a console they're
willing to do that it's in sony's
interest
to be able to keep up with the demand
because the scalper will always
charge more so it's a it's a short-term
gain in response to a shortage of supply
relative to
um a high amount of demand but it's
non-sustainable so it's like it's
because you know sony will be responding
to that market demand
far more effectively and in a way that's
more advantageous to the consumer
this is what happened with in the end
that's the best case scenario
and we'll ultimately win in the
capitalist marketplace right like they
will
do the best job of providing yeah you're
right yeah cool
that this was also what happened with um
where it can change the industry is what
happened with uh uh cabbage patch kids
like that was those things were going on
the the black market
and it it shifted i remember that yeah
it was it was something that was
what was the one what was the one in the
90s um that was the sort of
one tickle me elmo was one well i mean
uh i don't know if you guys have any of
those pokemon cards right now edition
one boxes are going for 20 000
and then because a couple of youtubers
bought them at 20 000 they went up to 50
and then went up to 70.
logic bought one for 200 000. crazy he
did get like five showers on stuff
and he has this like baby though like
here's my son or his
uh his baby is like sitting there
gnawing on a 200 000 card i'm like
you made a lot of money off that single
homie yeah
um but that's been art trading for years
right that's that's the
that's every every millionaire who ever
bought picasso that's the same
[Music]
to an extent that's an interesting way
of looking at it
i don't think the production of electric
cars peaked in 1912.
yeah i looked it up also energy.gov
has a article on the history of the
electric car and the first one
was revealed in 1890. that wow
i can't believe that i had such a
massive i'm sorry for that i think it
was not go far
they could go like 14 miles an hour yeah
probably something that can go longer
distance because we was going to say
because the battery would be the thing
the batteries because that's why
electric cars are now becoming very very
viable is the battery storage
they just brought back the mgb did you
see that there's a company in the uk
that's making the mgb in the original
style but it's all electric
and it's going for like seventy thousand
pounds
it looks given how our economy is doing
that's about five dollars though
so you know it's it's not it's i didn't
expect to learn any of this today that's
damn good so i my my my take maybe i've
like dominated the time on this but i
i think it's it's
bad sure um but i think that there's a
fool
or pulling his money or questions
scalpers yeah
yeah they said the fool and his money
are soon parted what is the phrase
um if there are people that are willing
to pay for it um
you cannot separate a fool from a
foolhardy mission
like they they will seek out foolhardy
things to do
um i don't think that sony that the last
thing i want to do is and then have to
create it's the same problem with
government you have to create government
in order to
police these policies to control
people's appetites you just can't do
that
i would i would say i've sorry
uh obviously speaking completely
independently here as a lot of peers and
not
sony whatever
don't do that stop uh i could see
goodnight everybody
either of any of the clubs um doing
a two-step verification for purchases
just similar to how theater world's done
it right like similar to how
because i'd be lying if i said i'd never
paid a scalper for like just for a show
ticket
right like that's definitely happened i
paid for sneakers
yeah i don't know and sneak sneakers
have the verification right sneakers
have
solved this problem theaters have solved
this problem to the extent no
no is that not true i thought they had
the verification process really bad for
sneakers
who are actually like being
scalped that's not really the right way
this is coming from
your best buys in your amazons and your
walgreens it's not coming from
you don't care right ultimately because
they're selling a ps5
either way like that so yeah so i think
and they're selling out of them
um but those are the people it's it's
actually the retailers that are the ones
that probably have the problem to solve
if they care but they have no incentive
to care
um but the sneak sneakers it's crazy
because it comes directly from the nike
app
uh the sneakers app sold out in seconds
every single time wake up at 6 55 a.m
try get the drop at it's it's virtually
impossible
for the record i don't think that they i
don't think that they
i don't think it's quite accurate to say
that they don't have an incentive to
care
because if i go to best buy for all my
console purchases and they have a very
hands-off policy about scalpers and they
are never in stock i'm
not going to go there again in the
future and there's not an
instant there's not an instant feedback
mechanism there but over time
you know what may have been a loyal
customer base will start to fall off
because they realize
i you know they don't care about me like
there
there is there is a market feedback i
think there
it's just slow it doesn't solve your
problem today
but it it's something that i don't think
that they would be immune from
and a lot of these companies do have
single single purchase only per customer
how does the theater solve that mike
because like yeah i remember
i bought um i was in london they haven't
fully like you can still see people
outside any theater selling tickets but
a lot of things
you also have a great system in place
too where it's like day of tickets you
know that you can get
uh same-day tickets for like for super
cheap i remember one time
i bought two tickets for two different
shows i was like i don't know
i i let pam decide like which one do you
want to go see do you want to go see
les mis for the 50 000 time or do you
want to go see
this other this other one and she chose
les mis i was like okay
though both tickets were waiting for me
at will call i even put up on twitter's
like i don't want these tickets to go to
waste
if you're in town go to the will call
they're there under this name and you
can get these tickets
and those people got together like i'm
i'm here it's like
fantastic have a great night at the
theater and we went to go see les mis
for the
libby i know i don't think so or maybe
maybe i had to call the theaters like
these people are going to pick this up
but i did it through twitter dm so i
mean i look that's that's me using the
system for
quote good sure you know but that same
system allows people
to be able to go outside i got two
tickets
tickets yeah you're gonna you're always
gonna go to a concert go to the theater
go
i hope i get a ticket i hope i get to
pay an exorbitant amount of money
yeah i see this thing that i should have
just prepared better for
it's different for sneakers sneakers is
like you can get up literally
at that like the the crack of dawn and
and not be able to get those things
every time every time i i'm curious how
big of a thing this
actually is in terms of like i i don't
know let's see
yeah yeah exactly like is this a real
thing or is this kind of a manufactured
controversy because a few people have
managed to sell you know multi thousand
dollars
i uh i just made a video about that um
how how can i watch a video on your
channel when i'm currently already on
your
we're in we're on another video right
now this is a different window
same matter can't occupy the same space
at the same time that's the only rule of
physics that people know
uh basically i can't go metal like that
um i'm not immune to this but it's
something that i try to remind myself of
as as often as possible is that we have
this habit of talking about things that
happen on the internet as though
well all these people are doing this how
many people
is it more exactly every every yeah
every like of that tweet is a million
people
you're representing like well all these
people are saying this
as though the two comments that you saw
are actually a hundred
um and and i think it's because it's
very difficult for us to read
something on the internet as being from
an individual we see it as being from a
hive mind
no matter who it's from and i think
that's like entirely relevant that yes
there there was a story that came out
about how some scalpers had more stock
of ps5s than stores like they it's not
necessarily there a lot of scalpers it's
that the scalpers that we've heard about
have a lot
of ps5s or xbox series x's and i think
that's why it's concerning
um but is it necessarily a lot of people
did not happen before with the previous
console generation that there was this
amount of i imagine
yeah i think you i think i think you
needed to pre-order if you wanted one
launch week but i feel like a couple of
weeks later you could walk into a store
and
maybe i'm remembering i remember the the
walking in and getting a ps3
like the day it dropped and there was
and it was like it wasn't even aligned
like it was not a big deal
i mean i i was in l.a assuming they've
had a lot of production problems right
like presumably there's been a there is
a there are less ps5s
in existence at launch than there have
been in previous years presumably right
basis the worldwide problems the
south park the whole conductor which one
do you go with do you go xbox should he
go playstation but the only one that i
remember is like we have we
was was that because it was just
everybody and their [ __ ] dog were
buying a wii
and you couldn't get one um do you
remember we for wii
u another competition
where they had uh people try not to go
to the bathroom for as long as possible
that was just an issue it might have
been i don't know where it happened
actually
how many how many how many uh how many
dialysis machines did that end up
but i think someone got really unwell uh
yeah like that's like sounds like kids
remember that the toyota hands on a
truck thing where you like yeah the
first was that era wasn't it the we came
out in that kind of
time of those kind of yeah it was
a radio station licensed to sacramento
no yes it's one of you wsac
sac radio hey everybody we're going to
do our uh annual we for wii
challenge who can hold their bladder
let's see if they can't get their uh
wait we got a mic somebody died what
somebody
just somebody died wow really absolutely
please throw cold water on troy
you oh
yeah somebody died turns out um
january 2007 katy is that not darwinism
is that
like if you die from that wow
did anybody else continue in the face
there's definitely yeah definitely
yes
and that's irresponsible for them to
haul that kind of competition but i
understand your point um
it's a bit dumb so the kdnd morning show
controversially held an on-air contest
in which contestants were challenged to
drink as much water as they could
without urinating
in order to win a nintendo wii video
game console a 28 year old participant
in the contest died of water
intoxication resulting in intercom being
sued for wrongful death by the
participants family
the fcc also investigated the incident
and in 2016 stated that it had placed
the renewal of katie andy's license
under review questioning whether the
station
had operated in the public interest
i think it shut
you can essentially drown yourself you
can drink too much water
that's how people most often die from uh
i don't know what the phrase would be
from ecstasy is that they drink too much
water
and drown themselves when they're on
ecstasy
because she feels they do that their
body keeps telling them they're
dehydrated yeah
that doesn't sound really been on a
journey this episode this is
a lot of a lot of full circles but i
just been all over malicious shop aren't
we guys
i i think uh to to close out the
scalpel's conversation look i think
scalpers suck
um as someone who likes sneakers it
sucks for me monthly like it's
it it they suck i don't think anyone's
arguing with that
but they think it's part of the reason
why they're deployed right it's it's
it's exploiting someone's um there
there is the the whether it's irrational
or not that the
the um the fear the fomo
you know vibe or or the fact of uh
sometimes it's people trying to get them
for their families which is hard for me
to rationalize because i never got a
gift worth five hundred dollars as a kid
no go outside you know play with the
pilot here's
i got a bendy ruler for christmas once
you know like just a ruler but it would
bend
and it was translucent and i was like
this is sick good times
it doesn't sound like an effective
measurement bracelets that you slap on
your wrist and they wrap around
that's all i needed that's all i needed
i got all my consoles second hand
this this let me just there's a one bit
of devil's advocacy that i could bring
to that though is that
in terms of it being exploitative is
that it's
everyone involved is voluntarily
involved
no one was forced to pay 10 grand for a
ps5
i look at that person and i think you're
insane especially since you can wait
however long um i think that's right
exploitative's not the right word
but yeah they are not coerced against
their will
they may not exercise great judgment but
that doesn't necessarily mean they
are uh it's exploiting some things if
someone has a feeling that says
yeah you're exploiting someone's own
fragility if your business model relies
on someone to have a flaw
then you're in dodgy ethical territory
right
now there's your interference between
someone who's just like i can and i will
so it's it's i understand it's not like
this feeding this scratching this itch
you know this this uh addictive behavior
necessarily someone's like i've got 10
grand that
honestly doesn't mean now i think that's
also an ethical if you can just blow 10
grand because you can
then you should probably be doing
something better with that money unless
you but again that
yeah i was going to say that's like they
so quickly end up in a place of like
well
now we're just assuming a whole lot uh
with and it's it's all this kind of
we're basically inventing a person
in order to bolster our argument also
the need also the needs
of the consumer is created by the act of
the skeleton
there's one less ps5 available in a
store because they
bought it up and sold it right so that's
that aspect of it that
that's why i was curious the scale of it
because if it were true that if
half the ps5s went missing because of
this then i would be like okay
that's clearly a there's like that's
[ __ ] up
uh like but that's also just find
anything i don't i don't think it's that
extreme
it won't be it won't be it'll be and
then i the the thing like you said the
scariest thing is that there's so many
units with one individual
because scalpers if they're someone
selling two tickets to a show they don't
want to see
like troy well troy gave them away but
you know what i mean like having two
tickets and getting rid of them
selling them all or giving them away
that's fine but like yeah when you when
you're like
half this theater is tickets that one
guy bought
that's when there's a systemic problem
that probably needs a fix that's so in
this case if that was the one that got a
lot of
traffic was a scalpel group in the
united kingdom
um sorry uh a scalpel group in the
united kingdom has secured almost 3500
playstation 5 consoles for resale more
than actual retailers
that's the one that's got that's
significant that's not
1 500 that's a systemic flaw they've
taken wonder how that's even physically
possible
so where are they holding them
for the record at retail price that's
almost two million dollars
like this person has like an investor uh
yeah
that's organized crime at that point by
definition i was gonna say yeah
so get mob [ __ ] right there there was a
pet there was the pet allegedly
allegedly allegedly sorry
the pepsi challenge if you collect
so many um tabs or or bottle caps or
whatever it was
and they did a commercial for it it was
like you can get this this this you save
up a million
you can the jump check it was the jump
jet
and it was a joke it was a total joke
but they didn't put on there
the fine print that said you will not
actually get a jump jet
now it is illegal that is a military
plane
that you cannot sell that to a civilian
just oh like a harrier
it was a harrier jet so the guy this is
vaguely ringing about this the guy went
and and and did the math and he was like
they didn't put any fine print i could
actually get them and he went to
a an investment firm and said i will get
it will take me 1.3 million dollars
worth of bottle caps to get what they
want
to to accumulate what is needed to get
that thing
like 100 million plane they can't get
1.3 billion okay yeah
so he said they cannot sell this to me
but they have to offer me the cash value
of that plane
and the or settlement company that's the
play
yeah there you go and he went and bought
it and he went to peps he was like
did it and they said well we were joking
it's like you didn't say you were joking
you have to give me the cash value of
that plan wow and they did and so he got
his percentage and other people got it
was like
and that's why in everything else yeah
all those things this is why you have to
sign a release just to drink
a coke now so he didn't like he didn't
get the money
like he didn't get the money he got the
money he has to do it
no they so they i remember that i
remember reading about the case because
it's it's like taught in
marketing schools now like this is why
you put [ __ ] fine prints on stuff
but he didn't get away with it because
there was a there was a loophole
which was it was something i can't
remember what it was but there was
basically coca-cola were able or was it
cocoa or pepsi it was pepsi wasn't it
pepsi were able to yeah pepsi were able
to prove
that it was fictional
or parody it was something like there
was a weird loophole they used
the other thing was he didn't buy the
bottle caps what he took advantage of
that's what it was so the the the
problem
was it was it was a it was a it was a
like a loophole because there was a
catalogue he didn't buy the bottle tops
but there was like a deal where if you
didn't have enough bottle laptops you
could top up with cash
um and he was trying to use that so he
actually had like five bottle tops
and a million dollars cash and said i
would like the the crazy expensive plane
but it was because it wasn't listed in
the catalog it was not
legally binding because you can put it
in an advert
as long as it's not in your for sale
catalogue and then when they send it in
because
pepsi presumably because a lawyer got
involved very quickly because pepsi
didn't give a receipt of
that's that basically if pepsi had
cashed the check
they would be absolutely like right you
have to give it to us but pepsi dodged
it slightly so they did get away with it
but like yeah it's
it was you've got to admit but yeah the
investment's the fun part that he went
because it was it was inevitable it's
kind of brilliant actually it's really
hilarious
like yeah just to get a settlement
that's why it works it's brilliant it's
really clever but you like you said
austin's like this guy
has to have an investor it's like maybe
well if you're buying two million
dollars worth of
players fives i guess you must right or
you'll or you
so it sounds like basically these
scalper groups exist on like a discord
and they do help people out
this article i was just reading says
that that the scripts were actually
started for
sneakers um and just around the
next gen launch of consoles they altered
them slightly
to be able to use them for consoles um
which makes a lot of sense why i can't
[ __ ] buy any sneakers
anyway um they're they're never the real
hackers that do it it's always it's
always the script
the script kids who like grab the script
and use that that's
always yeah it's never the out there
with the sweet
sp dunks goddamn you anyway um so there
they port the the script from the
sneakers to get the consoles
and it's basically like these large
discord communities so they could be
saying that they have 3500 but that
would probably be the entire discord
community has that many i
see rather than an individual person in
a warehouse that's how much
person on there has gotten a couple and
you pay to join the community
okay yeah so as a collective pay to get
into the community that's yeah
so they're all so pyramid scheming
some kind of thing in place where you
can't there's a family guy episode where
you you're operating a business
right so you would have to be a licensed
retailer in order to do that
otherwise you're breaking a law i
definitely think it's illegal
yeah so that it's scalping
well but there are but well i don't know
though i actually i'd be curious to find
out because
if i if i have a garage sale and i'm
selling my ps4
that's not illegal i think that's
different i have to i just look to the
clock i have to hide out guys i'm sorry
i'll see you later
i'll send you the audio now we get to
talk about you all right yeah
look at our weird checkerboard episode
of like yeah oh my god we're like
rotating out now let's bring in
strangers and just gradually
it was the get lance mcdonald we we
because we do our we do our like
thanksgiving trip and we've done this
this is our 10th year
and every year has looked different and
it's gone everywhere from like we had
like a
gourmet chef come up and prepare meals
to like getting
too high and having frozen red bear and
pizzas
so like frozen red bear and pizzas are
not like a standard that we have
um and like the the meal that we had
for thanksgiving was red baron pizzas
mashed potatoes with pancetta
and something else weird like it was the
weirdest
alteration of like there's no turkey and
dressing and cranberry sauce and all
that stuff
i hope it's like pad thai or something
like that yeah like
just a little pad some sashimi yeah um
never not worth not in the mountains um
but are you committed to this or not huh
are you committed to this bit or not
like i i just i want to be alone
i'm curious to see if um if if there is
some legality i would love for people to
kind of sound like
was one of you about to explain the
legal difference of a garage sale though
or your thoughts there like
there's mike did the deal i wasn't like
taking that with him was it
lee he might be the same thing that the
same thing we're talking about as far as
like uh
independent contractor law like if
you're gonna do it weekly
or on on any kind of recurring that's
where the government steps in goes no
but if you advertise for it and you do
it repeatedly then you're operating a
business if you're inviting people to do
commerce out of your home
that's where it gets tricky but a single
a single
scalper selling one ps5 then would not
be
illegal by that the thing that i think
might be illegal
is actually the bots in the first place
why i'm not sure
yeah but i wonder if there's a law
against that um i'm not sure
i really don't have anything to base
that on but you're right that it i don't
know why it would be illegal to just
sell
things that you legally have acquired i
mean that's that's the entire business
model of craigslist
yeah right auto trader of ebay that's
that's the whole thing
and it's very useful to people like it's
like you look like if you need
cash and you sell off some furniture or
whatever like that's like the difference
that's a time-honored way to get some
money
you're going to a platform that is in
business to do that
right so there's a difference between me
functioning as my own ebay
and doing that on the regular and going
through etsy going through
ebay going through craigslist which is a
platform
that is a business for
you know uh making people do this with
their
fingers well according to the website
keen gamer published uh it's like a drug
report
yeah i have no idea i have no idea the
validity of this but uh they said
i just googled is ps5 yeah exactly
um they say it is not illegal basically
uh ticket sales scalping is the only
thing that there is any kind of specific
legislation on
uh but um but it says that while
basically while people don't like it and
it's not very popular and it does look
like there's essentially some kind of
abuse going on
there's no law being broken at least in
the u.s
interesting according
but because it doesn't hurt those
companies nobody's ever had any
incentive push
to pursue a lawsuit so there's never
been a precedent because amazon has
never been like how dare you
buy 300 of my product i love how troy
loved the word precedent you knew it you
knew
you know me so i saw it in your eyes the
way i said it precedent
yeah it's like
[Laughter]
we are in sync today um
yeah i uh yeah you know it would be
interesting i don't know what
i don't know what the incentive for say
amazon
to to
uh i just don't feel like like ban users
for that yeah i don't i don't really see
uh i mean that's because it would also
represent accidentally sending people
the wrong thing
uh that's been a thing where people are
expecting to get ps5s and then they get
like a shipment of underwear instead
um but i don't know that that could be
blamed on something
today
[Laughter]
what i especially love is it's like it's
like lingerie
and you see you see the guys you see the
guy's girlfriend being like
oh my god that's amazing he's like yeah
or the who's this for yeah what are you
not telling me
who said there's a lot of ways that can
go yeah
so i'm picturing all that in your
neighbor's apartment yeah and all of
your
maybe that's what it is man the unboxing
went bad next
intense um did we have an intro the show
no but you can do it well hi everyone
welcome to play watch listen
i'm alana that's troy and that's awesome
mike already left
i was gonna i was i was hoping you just
wouldn't mention mike let's just he was
here
it is dap a little christmas sweater he
looked great but he's gone now
um and he even got a little youtuber
light ring
yeah yeah he looks so fancy now also
troy you look very fancy today
you dressed up dude i'm i'm lu limit out
like i am i've gone
hardcore like yoga pants
athleisure is that a term yeah yeah
is that like a category that is not a
billion dollar industry i've never heard
of
not billion but i mean it's definitely
like blue limit has been like hey you
can wear this to the office and people
won't look at you funny
i've just never yeah i mean i i know all
about them you want to know something
weird that
i don't know for sure that this is true
but it strikes me as just
patently absurd apparently the canadian
founder of lululemon
called it that because he was
he basically loved the idea of how
difficult that would be to
uh for japanese speakers to pronounce
he's a bit of a prick
is that so that's a choice yeah true
story like i don't know if it's a true
story but it wouldn't surprise me just
because
he he is a there's not there's not a lot
that's canadian about him
because there are people going hey you
know your your clothes are
pretty much made for like a body type
and he goes yeah don't you think you
should maybe offer your clothes
to to people who are just a little bit
more body diverse
and he goes no they shouldn't wear my
clothes i was like
okay yeah so okay right up there along
the way
i guess but damn right alongside
keengamer the website nextshark.com
says lululemon founder named the company
because it was funny to watch japanese
people try to say it oh my god
can you believe that that's i i i'm like
and it's a huge company now like and at
the idea that there's just this guy like
i like this wannabe mr burns um
i'm just like so [ __ ] up it's so and
it's baffling that like
his thing actually played yeah troy burn
it yeah sorry
canceled um yeah yeah how much does this
cost
where oh my god i don't remember where i
don't remember where i first heard that
story but that was one of those where i
was like that is a very esoteric
like i have a hard time coming up with
track titles
but like the idea of this really
explains
that was a good one that one turned out
all right i had i had help with
from the music supervisor ubisoft on
that one
[Music]
a mess i'm glad i um own any of this
stuff now because to me yeah
to me to me like the idea of sitting
there and not thinking about like
the philosophy of athleisure or whatever
but just sitting there going like oh you
know it would be hilarious
i'm there were several conversations and
back and forth so we didn't have a name
for the first episode because we hadn't
decided yet
austin still holds on to the original he
won't you absolutely still
my file extensions is up and adam i had
to be like it doesn't work for any
there's no marketing service for that
name whatsoever
but i do like it uh
but imagine we've just been like what if
we just made something like racially
inconvenient
yeah i got it guys hey but how about
this
yeah i just uh we call it the n word
yeah exactly such a viral like think of
think of the clicks and engagement yeah
it is
itself that's good that's what we do
guys we just we just call it it is
let's put it out there yeah it is
astounding that that guy
yeah and apparently his his joke like he
he left that one all the way to the bank
it seems oh yeah that stuff's very
though so he like gets paid and
you know it's paid in 30 percent and
mountains
horses and if you if you're currency you
could say
a loonie a loon come on it's true it's
not real so stupid not real
i do love it though i'm pretty sure that
that uh
what was the what was the was it was it
a was it a book or a movie about like
the this secret thomas jefferson thing
where the u.s bought canada
uh it was like it's like a da vinci code
type novel out there
it was like funny if you look there was
this big like one of the
when we started doing thanksgiving like
the the love is to say
play that bing crosby holiday radio from
pandora and it just like it sets the
mood we like christmas candles and we go
hard
for a month for christmas um
but there's this one makeup maliki is
the thing to say and there's this big
hawaiian surge in the 50s and early 60s
for hawaiian culture and it was like
that's
everybody wants to go to hawaii you need
to visit hawaii it's this beautiful
place and we love hawaiian culture and
hawaiian music and we did elvis movies
in hawaii all of this
because the united states bought a state
and they had to make their money back
and so they infused culture
with how great hawaii is and got
everybody
in america to say that's where we go to
go to vacation
every so manipulative it's so
manipulative
well that's where no it's not that it's
it's not that it's manipulative it
it but it is that it is that there's
always a bigger context there's one of
the things i love about neil degrasse
tyson when he talks about
the reason we went to the moon was never
the the adventure of of exploration or
the scientific exploit it was like we
needed to prove to the soviets that we
could
launch accurate rockets missiles
that we had a very robust and thriving
intercontinental ballistics program that
was what that was about it was a signal
and it was a response to sputnik
also probably it was a response to
sputnik uh but we also did skylab too
and that was that wasn't necessarily the
best but that was that was
still cold war much later but much later
but it was also
probably to cover up the fact that we
were launching satellites like we were
just
throwing those things out like a yeah
but that's
that's the point businessmen on payday
at a strip club it was just like
we were putting satellites up in space
like crazy
as a final piece of trivia something
that i've never actually thought about
before and it's so obvious but i've
never really
put two and two together jar jar you
know hawaii
hawaii became a state in 59 which means
that when pearl harbor was bombed
hawaii was not actually a u.s state it
was not it was just a place where we put
a base and that's one of the reasons
probably why we bought it it's because
we're like all right
all right we got pulled into a world war
over this over this place
uh i i never really thought about the
fact that hawaii like
the amer the massive amount of american
navy that was stationed there
uh that that was those were not like
american citizens
uh living there there were there were
two places
where were they was it like puerto rico
was it a territory it wasn't a territory
it was just a naval base like we had
guam and we had
um because there was a lot of activity
that was happening in the south pacific
and we needed a go-between on the east
seaboard or the eastern seaboard and the
western seaport
and these hawaiian islands were perfect
wow
that's a jump off point to this was it
was it just an independent nation
uh this is this is the life i feel like
i should know
like yeah was did they did they did they
self-govern
as a as a as a as a nation
like as a nation state or was it
basically just
sort of a nationless local community on
on a string of islands no they had a
governorship
like they they had their own but they
were very desperate
i need to know the answer to this this
is something very
uh the us also sold alaska
or almost sold alaska to russia
closer sarah palin got in there and was
like no
i guess sarah palin's before you google
heavy episode
so march 30 1867 the united states
reached an agreement to purchase alaska
from russia so russia did
uh oh in alaska at a certain point
and that's when we discovered all the
gold we're like hey can we uh there's a
lot of gold and oil can we buy this from
he's like yeah what do you want for that
i would just like it it's not attached
to our country at
all but we thought we think it'd be cool
to have like a completely
we have to create a new word
non-contiguous states
there's only 48 of them i think the
reason they did it
we'll give you florida was something to
do would be very interesting if
not wanting russia to be that close to
the u.s
so they were trying to take it over you
just be like
yeah they were pretty much trying to
make sure that russia was further away
so they bought alaska
from russia um there were very few
russians over there because alaska is a
useless land mass
you really can't get much done my
favorite thing
about when i visited alaska was learning
that uh sometimes in the winter if they
want to keep their meat
stored for a really long time they will
bury it in the snow
because it gets cold enough that that is
more efficient than storing large
amounts of meat in a freezer
you can just bury your meat outside in
russia
fascinating stuff don't know how we got
here either well all right
i looked it up because it was bog it was
bothering me it didn't seem it didn't
seem possible that that we just had a
base on some independent
territory that was not officially part
of the us apparently
uh it was an officially annexed
territory ever since
1898. what does that mean hawaii meaning
like like in a way i think analogous to
puerto rico
it was under the domain of the us but
they did have a degree of
self-governorship and they were not a
state which meant they did not have the
rights
of full citizenship the way people in
california and et cetera
but it was under the sort of banner of
u.s
broader territory um
so yeah apparently there you know good
60 years worth of
sort of belonging to the u.s um
uh in to a degree it looks like um
fascinating stuff and
yeah i i it was bothering me that i
didn't know that i've been to hawaii a
few times and it's
just freaking beautiful there it is
every time that i
flew home back in the day i used to stop
in hawaii for three days because it's in
the middle
of maybe mostly because it's beautiful
but it cuts the flight in half and cuts
the time zone
difference in half yeah so it's such a
nice way to make that transition
it's wonderful i flew uh our last before
my father died our last
family vacation my dad just one day just
goes i'm
we're going yeah we're going to go to
kauai and he he just
randomly decided to pay for everybody uh
and um and um flew us out there it was
it was very it was
never did anything like this before and
it was he had no idea he was sick
uh so it's like this it's like this
grand finale but we took a helicopter
ride like on the freaking jurassic park
flight path
and [ __ ] was that just one of the most
amazing things we heard the same thing
and we actually asked our helicopter
pilots like could you do me a favor
and i know that surprise sounds super
cheesy and touristy goes i've already
got it queued up
[Laughter]
and we flipped it i was like
they are real
i like your characters all coming to the
fourth they do move in hurts i knew you
would come
goddamn by the way we laughed so hard at
that that notion
because can you imagine being that guy
he like just stands there he wa the way
that he walks out as the whole thing is
crumbling around
he's just like the [ __ ] guys you come to
my house
and you destroy it i was fine i didn't
want to die today
i was just ready to leave like i'm gonna
go off and see the world
and you know and you trash the place do
you know why we don't lost the seal
do you know why we don't feel that way
when we see him standing there
why i felt that way we don't because of
john williams
because of this
you just don't feel bad for a guy when
you're hearing that you're like he's
this is what he was for this is what
this is he's fulfilling his mission
the score the score pushes us exactly
all right well what i want to picture
what i picture is that he doesn't get
buried it just
seals him in and then he's like [ __ ]
um alrighty everyone uh it's gonna be an
extra long episode i guess but that's
okay
we will see you all next week